you know that game you play with your
friends called would you rather
well we made an entire show out of it
would you rather we'll present you with
two dangerous weird or absurd scenarios
and
then we'll walk you through both of them
what episode might have you choosing
between
fighting 100 duck-sized horses or one
duck-sized horse and on another we'll
have you jumping into
a pool full of quicksand or a pool full
of piranhas
check it out
uh oh there's something crawling in your
food
oh wait that is your food
are you grossed out by the thought of
eating insects
what effect would eating bugs have on
your body
and could they become a major part of
your diet
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you only ate insects for the rest of
your life
15 states in the eastern u.s are
expecting
billions of brood ex cicadas to make
their way to lawns
parks and golf courses you might view
them as pests while
others see them as a scrumptious
arthropod buffet
yeah you heard that right people are
eating
insects welcome to the world of
entomophagy
two billion people around the world eat
insects
as a traditional part of their diet next
time you're at your favorite restaurant
could they be serving cricket tenders
beetle burgers or
fried cockroaches you can eat that
what's that no yes no well people have
been eating insects for
a long time ancient romans love
beetle larvae reared on flour and wine
the fourth century greek philosopher
aristotle even had particular
recommendations for
the ideal cicada yes at first the males
are better to eat but
after copulation the females which are
then full of white eggs
if the thought of eating a bug
completely grosses you out
don't feel bad it could have a lot to do
with your cultural background
in parts of mexico they eat ant eggs
soaked in butter
chocolate glazed locusts and candied
worms
in thailand bars and street markets sell
crickets grasshoppers and
a variety of worms in ghana
bugs are 60 of the dietary protein
of people living in rural areas you
might find all these ideas
unappealing but insects are quite
nutritious
in general most are rich in protein
healthy fats and vitamins and low in
carbohydrates
so if you rely on chicken or beef as a
regular part of your menu
you'd be surprised to learn that
replacing them with crickets or
mealworms
would be a healthier choice
you could also tailor your insect diet
to meet
most of your vitamin needs if you lack
iron
you could try a tasty snack of
gonambrasia balina or
iron-rich moths or if you were looking
to build up muscle
you'd prepare your gym routine with a
cricket powder protein shake
you can already see a variety of insect
protein
powders flowers and pastes on offer at
your local supermarket
so you might want to get used to it
according to a report from the united
nations food and agriculture
organization
as the global population grows insects
will need to become more prevalent in
human diets
if the thought of eating bugs makes you
queasy
keep in mind there could be enormous
benefits to the environment
insects have a feed conversion 12
times higher than cattle that means they
can more efficiently turn feed mass into
body mass
if you and many others converted to more
insect-rich diets there would be a
significant reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions water pollution
and
land use of course if you only ate
bugs for the rest of your life you'd
want to prepare them in as many ways as
possible
maybe grab a few cookbooks one thing's
for sure your new diet
would never get boring there are about
1900
edible insect species and like many
other foods they can be cooked
baked fried or even dried
and they take on the flavor of added
ingredients
okay maybe crunchy exoskeletons aren't
your cup of tea but
try to think of it like biting into a
delicious cracker or
chip or crisper
despite all this giving up every part of
your diet for bugs
wouldn't be entirely good for you
insects lack vitamins a
c and e that are important to your body
if you couldn't make up for those you
could be on the road to a
slow painful death from scurvy
but why not prepare for the future and
start mixing insects in with some of
your fruits and vegetables
i think i might be unknowingly doing
that anyway this is going on facebook
smile
[Music]
or go ahead and invite some friends to
brunch
anyone up for a stack of banana bug
pancakes
well enjoy those while you can because
our planet
might just run out of insects but
that's a story for another
what if
[Applause]
you